en plein désert du negev ce luxuriant
verger de grenadiers pourrait passer
pour un mirage mais il représente
surtout une victoire de l'homme sur les
éléments à siegen ses draps et ria comme
vous le voyez c'est une zone aride ici
oui il n'ya pas de verdure on devrait
voir que du beige normale et décale
cohen est à grenoble pour m'achever
hanegev une des nombreuses coopératives
agricoles qui avec les kibboutzim ont
forgé le secteur agro alimentaire d'un
israël naissant depuis la création
d'israël il ya 68 ans il a fallu trouver
une solution au problème de l'eau tout
nouveau moteur le negev représente 60%
du territoire israélien pendant les dix
premières années de son existence
israël a souffert d'insuffisance
alimentaire sa population rationner
l'eau était au coeur du problème
il a donc fallu innover et développer
des méthodes d'irrigation direct et le
goutte-à-goutte des techniques qui
élimine les pertes du précieux liquide
la véritable révolution ici c'est dans
ce bassin qu'on la trouve une sécheresse
alarmante qui s'est prolongée pendant
sept ans de 2005 2012 à forcer israël à
devenir champion en matière de recyclage
plus question de jeter les eaux usées
tout ça est devenu possible quand on a
commencé à recycler les eaux usées de
beersheva et d'ofakim vient des cultures
qui ne peuvent tolérer la chaleur et ne
pousserait pas mais depuis qu'on recycle
l'eau on peut faire presque tout ce
qu'on veut aujourd'hui 86 % de l'eau
rejetée par les villes et villages
d'israël et purifier et recyclés pour
irriguer les terres agricoles
parallèlement aux programmes de
recyclage
israël a dû chercher de nouvelles
sources d'eau fraîche et potable c'est
vers la mer que l'état hébreu s'est
tournée
l'usiné de sorek construite et opérée
par une compagnie privée et la plus
récente de quatre usines de dessalement
par osmose inversée une technique de
filtration sous pression à une seule
usine produit et revend à l'état 150
millions de mètres cubes chaque année
soit environ 20% de la consommation
domestique pour tout le pays en est à
sept longueurs d'avancé d'israël un
modèle pour plusieurs pays qui ont soif
de savoir faire et de connaissances mais
pour plusieurs de ces pays qui sont aux
prises avec la rareté de l'eau et les
sécheresses exacerbée par les
changements climatiques
le défi c'est aussi de trouver les
moyens de mettre en place des politiques
qui peuvent être très coûteuse 12 mètres
domine
amy est venue du tchad un pays qui a
coupé toute relation diplomatique avec
israël en 1973 la guerre de yom kippour
mais ça n'empêche pas le fonctionnaire
de ces journées avec ce groupe
d'africains pendant un mois aux frais du
gouvernement israélien dans l'espoir de
rapporter chez lui des solutions criant
besoin d'eau maintenant il pleut avec un
grand retard et ça joue énormément sur
la production alimentaire dont il ya
tous ces facteurs là qui influence sur
la filasse de l'homme la vie de l'homme
la vie de l'homme est lancée
face à cet élément il menace qui pousse
ses concitoyens à la migration dit ému
de la transhumance les déplacements de
la population est lié à tous ces
facteurs
parce que c'est le changement climatique
ce que j'ai vu aujourd'hui c'est spécial
a donc cette technique si l'afrique doit
faire un développement durable il faut
nécessairement appliquer ça lui met en
pratique cette technique
mais les techniques et les technologies
de pointe développées par israël ont un
coût ici ce sont les citoyens qui paient
la facture à la consommation ce qui a
permis le développement de toute une
industrie de l'eau mise en vitrine
dans cette foire internationale de l'eau
pour acquise
l'eau est un bien on le voit avec son
prix saute partout beaucoup de pays
comprennent que si on ne considère pas
l'eau comme bien qu'il faut payer le
système ne fonctionne
il y a un besoin et il faut s'adapter
dans un moyen-orient a séché l'accès à
l'eau est plus que jamais un enjeu
stratégique
israël partage sont accueillis faire
avec la cisjordanie et affirme fournir
aux palestiniens est plus que ce qu'il a
l'obligation de faire en vertu des
accords de paix et palestiniens disent
que ce n'est pas assez et que c'est trop
cher
l'eau devrait être pompe vers la paix
nous en avons la capacité si nous
arrivons à travailler ensemble
nous fournissons déjà de l'eau à la
jordanie et nous allons augmenter les
quantités
nous fournissons de l'eau à l'autorité
palestinienne mais pas assez nous
pouvons faire plus mais ces
considérations géopolitiques sont à
l'arrière scène du grand rendez vous
commercial de l'eau à tel aviv
plus d'un milliard de personnes
souffrent du manque d'eau et de
l'absence de système sanitaire de
nombreux pays partout dans le monde ont
besoin de solutions
des milliards de dollars doivent être
investis
et le petit pays qui a su faire éclore
le désert à force d'ingéniosité espère
qu'une bonne partie de ces milliards
seront investis chez lui
et si vous voulez en savoir davantage
sur la conférence de paris je vous
invite à consulter notre dossier web
vous voyez l'adresse à l'écran